hello my name is kayo day away me I am
an actor and writer and here are five
ways to help you demolish creative
blocks a creative block is when you're
either creating something making
something and your mind has totally
switched off you feel like anytime you
go and write that song that script you
go and make something you hit a brick
wall have you experienced that what I
would suggest and what helps me is
getting a blank sheet of paper some
coloring pencils pens and just start to
sketch in a piece of paper your sketch
and a set a timer for 2 minutes then 5
minutes then 10 minutes why why because
as kids this is what we used to do and
as kids you had this element of play of
fun of imagination coloring down helps
you get any energy any stress any bad
vibes on that sheet of paper the paper
would then tell you how you're feeling
draw down whatever you want however you
want after that then try again try and
make that thing again try and create
again and you will see don't be a change
when you read watching listen why don't
you read something you haven't read
before watch your film you wouldn't
normally watch a different genre or from
a different era listen to songs you
would never listen to listen to songs
with no words listens to rock rap
hip-hop jazz contemporary try and see
things hear things that you've never
heard or seen before it will help you
and I will open your mind to a whole
different world so this is what you
should do get a notepad or something you
can write notes in jump on any random
train or random bus and take it to the
last stop as you have taken this bus
will just rain write down what's around
you write down what you see or in fact
that idea might just come to you and
make sure you get it down because now at
the time normally for in the same
environment the same room the same place
you see the same thing two at a time and
there's no room for inspiration so go
out there get out of your room
get out of your house and let the world
take you on a journey learning an
instrument requires diligence patience
and concentration for me for example I
started to learn an instrument at the
age of twenty-two and now twenty five
and no I'm not the best but anytime I'm
writing a script or trying to create
something and I can't do it I go away
and I play the keyboard for a bit or I
go on YouTube and I look at how to play
chords on a guitar
why because for example would the guitar
unless you get the right chord you will
not hear that sound and that's the same
of writing unless you get the right
thing the right characters it will not
be what it needs to be so instruments
teacher diligence how to keep on going
and keep on going till you get what's
right so learn an instrument I'll say
the guitar it's nice it hurts your
fingers door
hey the vomit draft is always the first
draft and it looks terrible it smells
horrible but this is what you need to
begin your journey if you don't get it
down and it stays here it's not helpful
you don't have to show anybody just keep
it to yourself
but make sure you get this draft down
forget about what people think forget
about what your mind is telling you and
just do what's right get it down
and begin your journey thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to recieve notifications
for new videos see you again soon